but politics is so nuts now and like so
you said you worked with stormy Daniels
I did work not in a porno film stormy
Daniels is in not she's in both knocked
up and the 40 year old virgin
we is really very we we never told her
we are we very early in our careers we
realize like if you ever need someone to
be naked in a movie you should hire a
pornstar because it's the easiest thing
they did that week
in general there it's not a situation
where you're like convincing a
mainstream actress to get naked instead
you're taking a porn actress I'm putting
her in a mainstream movie and she
doesn't have to put anything in her and
so she's super scenes in these films and
story played a stripper in the in those
films were you considering her for life
she was for awhile gonna be here so I go
way back
she didn't tell you the oldest stories
Ben yes then she did tell us that she
had had a relationship with Donald Trump
and at the time when a flower tells you
they have sex with Donald Trump it's the
least interesting thing you'd heard that
day it was the most expected information
you expect to hear and literally was not
interesting to me I was ago yeah great a
porn started sexual thoughts like yeah
that's exactly what I would expect to
happen years later it became pretty
relevant information and I was like do I
say something I don't think I should say
something I think that's a socially
depleted right Seth I think you know in
general
[Music]
you